hey you guys time once again for the
movie retrospective and again Tom didn't
get a chance to watch this movie like
before I had to do the recording so I'm
gonna fly solo on this one again uh
hopefully nobody Minds all that much
so Italy
although I will say that this reputation
that they have is sometimes not
justified I mean because Italy obviously
had um you know it was pretty well known
for its many excellent original
contributions to the art of world Cinema
uh but you know you have to admit Italy
did have a bit of a reputation during
the 1970s and 1980s for making kind of
cheap knockoffs of pretty much any
American movie that was you know in any
way financially successful like you know
Jaws came out and then Italy comes out
with great white which is also called
the last shark
um you know for every Star Wars there
was a star Odyssey for every Raiders of
the Lost Ark there was ARCA the Sun God
you know what I mean like every time
something big would come out like they
would do their own take on it so because
William franken's The Exorcist was such
a huge Smash Hit and a huge cultural
phenomenon also back in 1973 you knew it
wasn't going to be all that long before
a soap called spaghetti version of it
would turn up in theaters and lo and
behold 1974 brings us the
Italian-American co-production beyond
the door now in Italy this was actually
released as kise I think is how you
pronounce it which just means who are
you which will make sense when you see
the movie
now since this movie features uh kind of
possession by a foul-mouthed demon a bit
of poltergeist activity 180 degree head
rotations and a whole bunch of green
vomit beyond the door was actually
deemed so similar to The Exorcist that
Warner Brothers sued the you know
filmmakers and they actually won a
settlement and that settlement entitled
them to I don't know how much cash they
got like they got some kind of
undisclosed cash sum and they also got a
percentage of any future Revenue that
the movie would bring in and despite its
kind of dubious pedigree I guess Beyond
the Door did rake in a pretty tidy
profit at the American box office it
only costs 350 000 to make you know more
or less and pulled in about 15 million
which is pretty crazy and I will say too
that like calling beyond the door just
like an exorcist knockoff isn't entirely
fair I mean yes the film's narrative
does borrow very heavily from William
friedkin's film
um but it isn't exactly the same story
and it kind of comes up with some
interesting ideas and maybe like even
some subversions of the genre like of
its own now I will say my main criticism
I think is that the movie is like
probably way longer than it needs to be
like I watched the international cut
which is actually on Plex and it was an
hour and I believe it was an hour and 47
minutes long now the original us
theatrical cut was only 97 minutes and I
haven't seen that version but I'm kind
of feeling like maybe that would be
better depending on what it was that
would that was uh taken out because the
movie being an hour and 47 minutes long
like some of the sequences do drag on
like way longer than they needed to and
kind of repeat the same information
unnecessarily and some of the dialogue
is like very repetitive on the whole
though I kind of feel like Beyond the
Door is just this very weirdly
compelling experiment I guess like in
its own right it's a weird-ass movie for
sure but there was something about it
there was like really appealing I know
it won't appeal to everybody because
this feel I feel like this gets almost
you know universally like negative
reviews but there's something about the
vibe a bit that actually I kind of liked
and enjoyed even though I did think it
like I said that I dragged in places but
I mean it has I don't know it just has
like all these really weird elements to
it that I enjoyed it had like these kind
of like really weird like musical cues
um had some really nice like
cinematography like very nice like use
of light and Shadow very dramatic in
places and a couple of scenes and images
in there that are actually like pretty
genuinely creepy so this was directed by
uh two guys like the first guy his name
is ovideo G assonitis and yes you may
suppress your Giggles now because I was
like assinitis come on that sounds like
get some preparation on that but I'm
sorry Preparation H on that uh so yeah
so asinitis and uh the other guy Roberto
piazzoli and those are the same two guys
that also collaborated incidentally on
another Jaws rip off which was called
tentacles which came out in 1977 which
is about a killer octopus so those two
guys directed it beyond the door was
actually successful enough that film
Ventures International it was like the
releasing company initially wanted to
release the kind of Mario Bava classic
from 1977 called Shock in the United
States as Beyond the Door too even
though it doesn't have anything at all
to do with the original film I think
there's like one actor that overlaps and
obviously doesn't play the same part but
yeah nothing to do with the original
film but that's kind of what they did
you know what I mean uh there was also a
third installment in 1989 which of
course was called Beyond the Door three
uh which also had [ __ ] all to do with
the original movie it actually went
straight to VHS now Mr acinitis
I can't I'm like I'm 12 years old I'm
sorry I'm sorry I know that's like it's
probably not funny like in the other
language but he actually like announced
in 2021 like just last year that he was
working on an actual honest to God
sequel to be on the door which would
actually feature Juliet Mills from the
original movie
um but we'll see if that ever
materializes like on Wikipedia it says
uh that it's supposed to be out in 2023
but we'll see so anyway at the beginning
of the movie uh we have a voiceover from
someone who is presumably the devil uh
being devilish and whatnot so on the
screen there's like this kind of whole
occult ritual deal thing going on and we
see like a nude woman stretching on a
pentagram who is eventually helped to
escape whatever her fate was going to be
sacrifice I'm presuming
um by a man named Dimitri now Dimitri is
played by Richard Johnson who horror
fans will immediately recognize as Dr
markway from the 1963 movie The Haunting
and also Dr Menard from Lucio full
cheese zombie so there's that
so because the devil is apparently angry
that Dimitri helped this woman get away
Satan makes his car go like go all
zigzaggy when he's driving one day and
the car like goes plunging off a cliff
but then he stops the car in midair and
he offers Dimitri a deal he says you can
have another 10 years of life if you
help this woman named Jessica deliver a
baby at some time in the foreseeable
future Jessica incidentally is played by
the aforementioned Juliet Mills who is
not only the older sister of Hayley
Mills but was also in the 1992 movie wax
work Lost in Time among many many other
things but that's what I had seen her in
now presumably the movie then jumps
ahead almost a decade and we're now in
San Francisco and we're following the
Barrett family so this is Jessica the
mom who we've already met her husband
Robert who's played by uh Gabriella
Lavia he was actually in three Dario
Argento movies matter of fact he was in
deep red he was an inferno and he was in
Sleepless as well uh yeah so those are
the parents and then they have these two
weirdo children uh their daughter Gail
and their son Ken now as this happens in
a lot of Italian movies the dubbing on
the kids is pretty atrocious but the two
kids like the [ __ ] that they say they
are like easily the most uh fruitful
source of the movie's intentional comedy
it's not funny usually but like the kids
like say funny [ __ ] like Gail who looks
like she's about I can't really tell how
old she is maybe 9 10 11 somewhere like
that
um but she like swears like a sailor and
uses like real like amusingly dated like
70s vernacular like all the time like
she'll say something like you gotta stop
that or it's gonna blow my mind man you
don't you don't quit crying you're gonna
have a real bad trip and like [ __ ] like
that it's like it's hysterical uh aside
from that like another one for character
traits which is just like random and
hilarious to me is that she also has
this inexplicable obsession with the
1970 novel Love Story by Eric Segal and
she always carries like a dozen new
copies of it like wherever she goes and
she's always reading it and it's just
like and they never explain it and it's
just like that's really really funny to
me so the younger kid Ken who looks
about four or five I guess
um he is also a little bit foul-mouthed
and uh he also his kind of character
trait that defines him is constantly
drinking Campbell's pea soup like right
out the can with a straw which I guess
that's like a funny little homage to The
Exorcist but it actually works because
hardly anybody in the movie draws
attention to it like I said it's just
kind of random nobody really brings it
up it's just like he's packing a lunch
box and he's putting cans of Campbell's
pea soup and but nobody says anything
about it you know what I mean so like
that makes it funnier to me that they're
not going going Hey look it's a joke you
know what I mean they're just kind of
like letting you pick up on it so one
actually one like small exchange between
the two kids that actually legitimately
made me laugh out loud when I was
watching this movie it happens like
right near the beginning and the kids
are like in the back seat of the of the
family convertible and they're you know
the parents are in the front seat and
they're kind of having a conversation
and like the dad's talking about I don't
know he said something about it's like
egotistical or something like that and
so the kids are in the back like kind of
talking back and forth about what a
loser their dad is and Gail says to Ken
like the younger kid hey remember that
crazy nickname you gave him what was
that and the little kid goes [ __ ] and
it was just like the comic timing of it
was just like perfect and I was just
like just busted up laughing and sorry
but little kids swearing will never not
be hilarious to me and I don't know why
that is so anyway we have like some
establishing scenes of this very
laid-back 70s California family like the
kids call their parents by their first
names and are kind of like allowed to
like I said swear like pretty much get
away with anything so amidst all of that
we learn that Jessica has just
discovered that she's pregnant again now
Robert seems ambivalent about this whole
situation as does Jessica matter of fact
but you know they I guess they figure
they'll deal with things as they happen
they're not going to ride too much of a
bummer about it man you know what I mean
like that's something like Gail would
say but it doesn't take too long for the
couple to realize that this isn't any
ordinary pregnancy now Jessica insists
now I shouldn't have even have gotten
knocked up in the first place because I
took the pill religiously even though
I'm like dude it's only like 99
effective that does give a little bit of
wiggle room you know what I mean and
I've known of several people that got
that did get pregnant on the pill so you
know it's it's not foolproof but even
barring that I mean she tells her doctor
who is also like a family friend his
name is George uh he's played by Nino uh
segarini actually
um that she last had her period like
seven weeks ago even though the fetus's
development he's like I hate to tell you
this but the fetus looks like it's about
three and a half months so it's like
twice as big as it should be
um you know so in other words the spawn
seems to be growing at an abnormally
like accelerated rate is what he's
saying so then like other weird [ __ ]
starts happening too like Robert starts
seeing a bearded man who we actually
recognize as Dimitri but he doesn't know
who that is
um he starts seeing him around San
Francisco and he appears to be like
following him he's like sees him like
he'd be sitting in a cafe and then he's
sitting over there like staring at him
and [ __ ] like that he's like what the
[ __ ] you know what I mean so he's like
following him around everywhere uh the
kids start seeing like some spooky like
Poltergeist type activity around the
apartment like their toys their dolls
start moving around in their own and
like their eyes start glowing and like
creepy [ __ ] like that uh worse than that
though Jessica seems to be pretty
steadily like losing her marbles I mean
it's like she will act like totally
normal one minute and then become like a
super aggressive rage monster the next
minute like one day for example she
heaves like a huge glass ashtray across
the apartment like through Robert's
prize aquarium like killing all the big
goldfish in there
um another day she belts Gale across the
mouth like for being a smart ass even
though she'd always been real indulgent
before like kind of let her do what she
wanted
um and then one time in George's office
she goes from like literally one second
she's like I want an abortion like this
isn't a good situation this Baby's gonna
hurt me blah blah blah and then like the
next second she's like screeching I'll
kill anybody who tries to take this baby
away from me blah blah like it's a
roller coaster of emotions that's for
sure so as the movie goes on uh Dimitri
finally approaches Robert and kind of
Reveals His identity now 10 years ago
Dimitri says um him and Jessica had a
thing they were in love or whatever but
he kind of says oh well I kind of
screwed it up and she left her what I
ever he also makes some kind of vague
references to some group they were in
which you know obviously it's like a
satanic cult right but he doesn't really
say that and maybe there's like some
negative energies man and stuff like
that and all of this might have
something to do with the baby in
Jessica's womb he tells Robert that
Jessica has to have the baby and she has
to have it at home under no
circumstances take her to the hospital
so Robert doesn't believe him at first
um but soon enough like Jessica starts
exhibiting some very very Reagan McNeil
type uh Behavior you know spewing green
bile all over the place speaking in
growly voices levitating there's
actually like a really cool scene where
she's like standing upright and like
levitating a few feet off the floor like
that it's like it's really well done
um and also causing some very violent
like uh paranormal disruptions around
the apartment like [ __ ] flying around
everything like that uh finally Robert
decides he's gonna allow Dimitri into
their house to help with Jessica against
Dr George's wishes I might add as
Dimitri really seems to be the only
person with any clue of what the [ __ ] is
going on here interestingly though
unlike uh The Exorcist there isn't
really any exorcism in this movie like
no exorcism takes place yes Jessica is
evidently possessed by the devil and yes
Dimitri does know what's going on and is
at her bedside like sparring kind of
with the entity that's possessing her
like in a similar way uh as you see in
The Exorcist but in this case Dimitri is
actually not really a good guy so it's
not like it's it's not like good versus
evil it's kind of like Super Evil versus
slightly less evil and also kind of dumb
you know what I mean it's like that kind
of situation
um it's implied actually that Dimitri is
either already dead or at least is in
some kind of like limbo pending the
outcome of the deal that he made with
the devil because remember like I said
he left the car like suspended see the
Prince of Darkness you'll remember gave
him 10 more years if he would facilitate
this birth and it's hinted that now that
the 10 years is almost up the devil is
going to let Dimitri's Soul be reborn in
Jessica's baby so that's why he's so
like head up to get in there and like
help out with the birth and everything
like that there's even a great scene too
where like Jess we're pregnant Jessica
is like floats up like a few feet and
she's talking like in the growli devil
voice or whatever and she's like telling
Dimitri to like basically like Ram his
hands up there pull the thing out you
know what I mean which I don't I don't
know that amused me too however poor
stupid Dimitri uh apparently forgot that
one of Satan's other appellations is the
father of lies and is therefore shocked
shocked I tell you when the devil says
to him essentially no I was just [ __ ]
with you
um I'm not really gonna let your soul be
reborn in the baby and he's just like
psyched that he's like he just lets the
car car that was suspended for 10 years
I'm presuming and nobody saw it all that
time I'd say It's Supernatural I'm not
going to worry about it but he just like
lets the car like fall to the bottom of
the canyon like into the ocean it's just
like sucks for you you're dead now
Dimitri haha uh you know what I mean so
he lied to him about all of that just so
he could get him there to do whatever
um basically the devil just said I was
just doing it to [ __ ] with you like he
didn't need him there or nothing like
that he was just doing it because he
thought it would be funny and like to
amuse himself for shits and giggles
essentially
um also uh he has the like the Jessica's
baby is born but then he causes it to be
stillborn and also it doesn't have a
mouth because you know he's the devil
and he's kind of a dick like that
um and then like at the very end the
final shot has like a seemingly
recovered Jessica I guess like the devil
got bored of being in there like once
the baby was born it's like bye I'm out
you know what I mean I'm gonna go
possess somebody else now I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go over to Reagan McNeil's
house see what she's up to so so yeah so
she looks like she's you know she's
still kind of [ __ ] up but she looks
like she's better her and so she's on
the boat and Robert's on the boat and
their two kids are on the boat they look
like they're on vacation or some [ __ ]
like that and then
um Ken the little boy he opens this
present which actually I thought was
kind of cool because you see the mom
Jessica like give Ken this gift like at
the beginning because like it's his
birthday like at the very beginning they
have like a little birthday party and
stuff and she gives him this present
that's wrapped in like black paper with
like gold ribbons on it and stuff but he
doesn't open it like at the party
because like some other [ __ ] happens
um so at the very end like she gives it
to him and he's opening it and inside
there's like a toy red car that looks
like the car that Dimitri got killed in
and then so Ken takes the little car and
then just takes it to the edge of the
boat and like Chucks everyone Chucks it
into the ocean and then like he turns
around and then like he has like scary
contact lenses and like you know so
you're led to presume that Ken is now
possessed because reasons so I guess
like the devil didn't go to Reagan
McNeil's house I guess he just went like
hopped over and he's like the devil got
lazy you know what I mean he's just like
well I just been in this pregnant lady
like all this time and it's like I think
I'm just gonna like hop just hop over
here like in the Next Room like into
this little kid this should be a fun
time so uh so that's what he did so I
guess like the kid's supposed to be
possessed now now I have to say like
Beyond the Door wasn't actually the only
Italian Exorcist knockoff hell it wasn't
even the only one that came out in 1974.
there was another one that came out in
1974 called the Antichrist which was
directed by um Alberto dimartino and I
haven't actually seen that one I've
heard it's pretty good though so I'll
probably like get around to it but you
know beyond the door like I have to
admit even though like I said this one
gets like generally pretty negative
reviews but I kind of had a soft spot
for this one um it's not a great film
I'm not gonna say that it's not a lost
gem or nothing but it's kind of like a
cool like a strange little artifact of
the era I guess it's got like some
really really like head scratching
scenes in it like there's one scene and
it's long it's like this extended
sequence where Robert is walking down a
San Francisco Street being accosted by a
man who's like playing a recorder like
or some kind of flute or something like
that like with his nose and it's a
there's no dialogue or anything like
that he's just like walking down the
street and there's like musicians like
walking along behind him going hey
[ __ ] with him and it goes on for like
forever and then there's like this weird
like jazz fusion kind of [ __ ] going on
so this guy's just like playing the
flute with his nose and I'm just like
alrighty so I don't know I don't know
what that was about it's just like weird
scenes like that in there
um it also has like some really decent
special effects they're very very simple
like there's no you know there's nothing
like super like uh over the top or
anything like that I mean mostly it's
just like puking up green stuff and but
there is one really great scene and it
was done like really simple with like
split screen but it still looks really
good where um Jessica is like laying
down in the bed
and like one of our eyes is like you
know just doing normal eye [ __ ] and then
the other one is just like rolling like
all crazy like all around it it looks
like really disquieting but because I'm
looking at going how the [ __ ] did they
do that and then I was like oh I guess
it was split screen but like the way
that they did it like you couldn't
really tell so it looked like really
eerie like it looked really creepy but
like I said it's really really simply
done they could do that back in the
silent movie era so you know what I mean
so it's not like I said it's very simple
but uh very very effective
um and like I said the score of this is
like really interesting too it's very
obtrusive and kind of scrawky but I
don't know I kind of dug it like for all
that now as I mentioned before like some
of the scenes go on way too long and
feature like way too much repeated
dialogue like there's one phone call and
this happens like multiple times but
there's one phone call like after
Jessica
um breaks Robert's uh aquarium like the
fish tank
um she's talking to him on the phone and
she keeps saying it wasn't an accident I
wanted to break it it wasn't an accident
I wanted to break break it I wanted to
break it I wanted to break it I was like
shut up oh my God I just wanted to like
smack her okay you wanted to break it we
get it she said it like she said it like
six times and I was just kind of like oh
my God but there was that happened like
a few times throughout the movie I'm
like man you could have like taken 20
minutes out of the movie right there
just by like having each line of
dialogue just said one time and then you
know it would have been a lot shorter
and like I said there's really no Gore
there's like no big it's not like you
know Lucio foggy or like a lot of
Italian movies from this time period
where they like went over the top like
with the guts and blood and everything
there's hardly any Gore in this that I
can even remember a very very little
nudity I think there was maybe she was
naked at the beginning but it was kind
of dark and you couldn't really see
anything so there wasn't like any tits
or nothing like that I mean if that's
what you're into but I'm just saying
that like exploitation Cinema from this
era like usually would have a lot of
that and this doesn't have any of that
um but I'm gonna say if you're into
Italian Cinema and possession movies
from the 1970s if you're into Diallo
movies you might be into this too even
though like I said it's not gory and
it's not like murders or anything like
that but it kind of has more of a Vibe
of a giallo movie than it does like a
straight outright like possession horror
movie if that's if that makes any sense
um but if you're into that kind of stuff
then you might want to give it a look
but let me know if you've uh seen it and
what you thought about if you've seen
any other Exorcist rip-offs that you
could recommend to me then that would I
would appreciate that as well and
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective I'll see you guys again on
the next one bye